We've all had, or been,
toxic friends at one point
or another in our lives.
But sometimes, it takes you a while
to recognize who they are,
or when you're being one.
There's the "Copycat,"
Do you like my new outfit?
I mean, I guess it looks
a little bit like yours.
It's..
exactly..the same.
It's..exactly the same.
Are you..copying me?
The "Negative Nancy,"
I can't believe I got that promotion.
So much extra responsibility, so much stress.
And it's a bunch more money too.
More money, more problems!
Duh!
And a bigger office..
Well, looks like you're gonna spend all
that extra money on furniture then.
The "Wild Child,"
Anna: Hey..
Man: No..
I need a place to lay low, and like,
so does Megan,
(Man stammers)
and Brad,
Brad: Birdy!
and Kyle..
Man: This guy..
Anna: And if you could uh..stash this somewhere..
I'll love you~
(Man screams)
The "Social Climber,"
I heard you're like, friends with like,
a FAMOUS person.
Can we be friends?
I like jogging too!
Hi~
Brad: No, get away from me!
OMG, that's totally what the friend of
a famous person would say!
Besties! Wait up!
And..the "Drama Queen."
(quotes Hamlet)
To be..
or not to be..
that is the question.
Whether 'tis Nobler in the mind
to suffer the Slings and Arrows
of outrageous Fortune..
It's just a parking ticket.
Or to take Arms against a Sea of troubles,
and by opposing end them:
What? Wh--You're gonna..fight it in court?
I-It's only $25.
To die,
You aren't dying..
To sleep,
Maybe you should take a nap.
No more..
What, are you for real finished?
(cries) JUST SHUT UP, YOU GUYS!
DO YOU KNOW HOW THIS WORKS?!
I TALK,
AND THEN YOU LISTEN
AND THEN YOU SYMPATHIZE
AND YOU GIVE ME ATTENTION!
(screeches gibberish)
If you have a toxic friend in your life,
and talking things out
just isn't gonna work,
then break it off.
Pull the plug.
Nothing healthy is gonna come from
that relationship.
Do it right now.
Do it RIGHT NOW.
I'll do it right now.
(softly) We need to talk.
I'd like to thank NuMe
for sponsoring today's episode.
They sent me a great curling wand set,
thank you guys!
It came with all these different like,
sized wands,
and I've been a fan of wands forever.
So it was great to like, try each one,
and then see the different looks
that you can get,
but this one
was by far my favorite,
because it gives me such..
long, gorgeously giant curls
that bring all the boys to the yard~
And when you do use the Argan oil,
I use it as like, a heat protectant.
It keeps your hair anti-frizz,
smooth, shiny, and healthy.
I get all the compliments.
You can use the coupon code "HOTFUDGE"
for 40% off the entire site,
free Argan oil,
and free shipping within
the United States.
You'll also have the coupon code "WATERMELON"
for $100 off any set,
and some free Argan oil.
I put links and discount codes
in the description below.
So be sure to check them out.
I'm Anna Akana.
You stay awesome.
Unless you're toxic.
Then goodbye.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara